Samsung has been offering wireless earbuds
for a while now, even before the AirPods,
but they never really took off.
The battery life was horrible, they had connection
issues, and then the price.
Well, about a month ago they fixed all of
that and for our 1-month review of the Galaxy
buds, I’ll have to say that they’re great,
and for many, they’re actually better than
the Airpods.
Now don’t get me wrong, the AirPods are
excellent, they’re almost perfect, but there
are a few ways the Galaxy Buds simply do it
better.
The first and most important thing is the
price.
You’re paying $130 compared to $200 for
the AirPods 2, and that can be a dealbreaker
for a lot of people.
Samsung had to price these competitively,
and they did.
They're mainly marketed to Android users ,but
some iPhone users may even choose to buy these
over the AirPods 2, so we tested the Galaxy
Buds with an iPhone and made a video on if
they’re worth it for iPhone users.
Of course, they’re a lot better with an
Android phone because you can download the
dedicated Galaxy Buds app, which I’ll get
into in just a minute.
Back to the AirPods 2, you can save $40 by
not getting the wireless charging case, but
the Galaxy Buds have that feature included
for the same price, and the great thing is
that Samsung’s S10 line of smartphones all
support reverse wireless charging so you can
charge these without a cable.
Realistically, you won’t always use this,
but it’s nice to know it’s there just
in case you ever do.
What’s great about the Galaxy Buds is that
they seal in your ears, so while they don’t
have active noise cancellation, they still
block out a good amount of background noise.
The AirPods feature an open design so you
still hear everything in the background, and
when you turn the volume up, people around
you can more easily hear what you’re listening
to.
If you’re the Buds with Android, you’ll
have the ambient aware mode and can tweak
the sound profile.
This is missing on iOS but the default settings
sound best to us.
Samsung also added Apple-like automatic sync
setup, but it's not as simple because of all
the permissions requests you have to accept.
The sealed design of the Galaxy Buds gives
you a lot more privacy, and it also makes
them sound louder than the speakers actually
are since all of the sound is sealed intp
your ear and can’t escape.
This greatly increases bass reproduction and
it actually helps them save battery life since
the speakers themselves aren’t as loud,
hence why they’re rated for an extra hour
of battery life compared to the AirPods.
Because of the seal, they’re also splash
and sweat resistant, just make sure not to
get any water into the speaker grille on the
inside.
The AirPods don’t offer this because of
the open design.
What I really love about the Galaxy Buds is
how subtle they are.
They sit flush in your ear with nothing hanging
out or wrapping around your ear.
It’s actually quite impressive how well
they fit and stay in your ears.
And I absolutely love that Samsung decided
not to put their logo on the face of the Buds,
so they look really clean.
Each bud has a touch surface that you can
customize, and overall it works quite well.
You can even change Bixby out for Google assistant.
They come with a charging case that's a bit
larger overall than the AirPods and has less
battery life, 7 hours of additional juice
instead of around 19.
That is a big difference on paper, but not
as big in the real world unless you use them
all day long.
For most, you can plug them in to charge for
an hour every 3-4 days and you’ll be fine.
For the buds themselves, Samsung rates the
galaxy buds at 6 hours while Apple rates their
AirPods at 5.
Taking a look at the Sound Guys truly wireless
test, the Galaxy buds are leading the pack
with 6.5 hours while the AirPods come in at
just over 4 hours.
That's a lot of positives for Galaxy buds,
so what are the downsides?
The biggest one for consumers is the volume.
For most quality content they are loud enough
because of the seal and the sound quality
is great for the price, but I really wish
they were louder.
The AirPods can get loud, too loud actually,
but that comes in handy when the podcast or
video you’re listening to is too quiet.
With the AirPods you have more headroom to
compensate, but in cases like this, the Galaxy
buds can be hard to use.
My other complaint is the mic quality, its
usable but doesn’t sound great.
Here’s a comparison.
The Airpods mic is closer and pointed at your
mouth, so you get much better mic quality
instead of having the mic flush with your
head which makes it harder to pick up your
speech.
Another limitation compared to the new Airpods
is no hands-free access to your virtual assistant.
This isn’t a big deal for me personally
but let me know if it is for you in the description
below.
Overall, just like with the S10+ and S10e,
I’m really impressed with the Galaxy buds.
They’re not perfect, but considering the
sound quality, convenience, features, and
price they are an excellent value, even if
you’re an iPhone user.
This has been Max with Max Tech, if you want
to see more video like this click that little
circle above, and check out our Galaxy buds
for iPhone users video right over here.
Thanks for watching and we’ll see you in
the next one.